it's laughable quite honestly are we
where we want to be no
not at all we all have to coach better i
have to coach better we got to play
better we understand that we've got to
you know we've got to figure out a way
in this last month of the season
to to to win a football game right and
it's we got another great opportunity a
great opponent coming in here
you know this weekend and i love
everything about this organization
my job
fans it's a great place and i'd say it's
a great place to work when things are
things are going well we know we're in a
bit of a slump it's it's not easy it's
it's not a it's not an easy place to
work sometimes you know because it's
it's it's the pressure of performing
right as athletes as coaches when things
kind of go
awry as they have
you know this is when we say okay we
look internally and we say okay how how
can we fix how can i fix doug peterson
first how can i be a better leader how
can i be a better motivator how can i be
a better coach to the to the players and
and still still get the most out of
these guys
doug peterson yesterday morning on wip
radio in philly i'm always fascinated
about these arrangements with local
stations for coaches and players to do
the regular appearance remember we used
to have the ben roethlisberger weekly
appearance on radio to break down
because
press conference you never get the kind
of depth and you never get the comfort
level where the host will ask the
question like
there's speculation that you don't want
to be here and that's what prompted the
answer we just heard you don't get that
in a press conference i mean sometimes
you do but you're more likely to get it
when there's back and forth for 10 or 15
minutes and it really makes me wonder
why these guys do it i think part of
it's in their contract part of it's in
the flagship station for the team but
but it really is
enlightening and i'm glad they do it
because it creates comments like that
and i don't know i hadn't heard
speculation that he wants out but uh by
the time the season's over maybe he will
want out chris no i i have heard that
speculation i i have heard that you know
i have a hard time believing it but i i
have heard that out there in the you
know the nfl
rumor rumorville um
i i would hope or think that's not the
case though now they have some work to
do there i mean obviously things are not
good but doug peterson has done a great
job there with the philadelphia eagles
and they've been very relevant ever
since he's taken over and they have an
attitude and a style of play when
they've been healthy that is fun to
watch so i really respect everything
he's done there they're in a tough spot
right now yeah the team you know old
injured yeah they missed on a few
players free agency whatever else he
could have coached better carson wentz
is in a rut
and they're in a tough spot and philly
as we know is demanding as hell i don't
know mike he's got a big decision to
make this week i'm one that says go with
jalen hurts carson wentz needs to break
everything gets blamed on him even when
the defense lets up a touchdown they go
oh carson wentz that's what they do in
philadelphia let him take a step back
reevaluate you need something anyways to
energize your team a little bit do
something maybe jalen hurts can do that
and give you a schematical advantage
because you can't prepare for some of
the things they might do and at the very
least okay yeah if it works great you've
jump started your team if it doesn't
work you could tell all the people in
philadelphia to shut the hell up and
we're going back to carson wentz and
jalen hurts isn't ready yet so i really
look at it as like a no lose situation
there and i think it is time it's time
just start jalen hurts shut some of the
haters up in the world see if he can do
something for you let carson wentz take
a step back and reevaluate his play and
everything about it
yeah the problem is the saints and their
great defense are great town this
weekend yeah wow let's just
have it then go ahead i mean it ain't
gonna look much better with carson wentz
right so
the the the
the dilemma that peterson faces if he
wants out obviously he's under contract
and maybe the eagles would be happy to
let him go but you know chris i've been
thinking more and more about
an angle that doesn't get used nearly
enough in the nfl and maybe this year it
will whether it's the charters
whether it's one of these other teams
the idea that you can approach a team
that currently has a coach under
contract
and work out a deal for compensation and
then approach the coach and work out a
deal for what he's going to be paid
we we haven't seen the john gruden type
transaction nearly as often as i thought
we would over the past 20 years we saw
herm edwards go from the jets to kansas
city to time when the jets were ready to
fire him anyway we saw dick vermeil
retire and then resurfaced with the
chiefs and there was some compensation
bruce erin there was some compensation
for the cars but we haven't seen the
classic trade even though it's not
really a trade because the coach does
have a huge say in it i just every year
about this time i start thinking why
isn't this part of the arsenal of
looking for a coach we assume it's a
rising coordinator a fired head coach or
a college coach
never is it considered on equal footing
the prospect of trying to hire someone
else's head coach but it's legitimate
it's there maybe it'll be peterson maybe
it'll be somebody else you know this
chargers job is very attractive the
texans job is attractive there's a lot
of teams out there
looking for coaches who either have
franchise quarterbacks or the
opportunity to draft a franchise
quarterback and i can't help but wonder
whether or not this is the year
that that maybe the eagles get a call
hey if you're not happy with doug
peterson let's talk about a deal or
maybe some other coach there's a phone
call to his team hey you know maybe it's
reaching the end of the road i wouldn't
be surprised if it happens i i mean it's
rare because just so
you know the times we're talking about
like with john gruden you know john
gruden was he was the hottest thing
going too it's just rare that a coach
that's really good who's built something
and it's kind of successful
wants to leave that and start somewhere
else new and again i have no knowledge
of doug peterson's feelings with the
philadelphia eagles or anything like
that all we know is you know things are
not as smooth as the last few years but
i i i would be shocked if he wants out
of philadelphia you know
i i really would with the history he has
there what he's built there yeah it's
not great right now but i would think
they have confidence they can turn it
around and i don't know i mean who is
that guy who would be that guy right now
that you would look at that would even
be in that conversation maybe other than
doug peterson that a team would go okay
we want to purge him we're willing to
give those picks and and that coach has
to be somewhat unhappy with where he's
at too
uh yeah i don't know if anybody you know
fits that mold other than doug peterson
right now if it is true that maybe he
wants out of philadelphia
there was a time i thought that was
going to happen with sean payton but i
don't believe that's going to happen
right now that he's got now that he's
got his successor to drew brees and i
think he he he kind of you know may i
don't know maybe was toying with the
idea of something like that but it seems
like he's locked into new orleans for
the long haul and he's going to be that
guy who you know is there 20 years if
not longer but uh yeah you have to you
have to find someone where maybe there's
some mutual disenchantment because
that's what was going on with the
raiders
al davis was ready to move on and they
only had him under contract for one more
year you consider he got two first-round
picks two second-round picks and eight
million for a guy who could have walked
away after one year that's amazing
but i just think that
with all of these jobs where the
quarterback isn't an issue most of these
jobs come open because the quarterback
stinks there's going to be several jobs
where the quarterback is good if the
chargers make a change obviously with
the texans as we've discussed the
opportunity to draft trevor lawrence
matthew stafford if if you like matthew
stafford i mean he's better than most
quarterbacks definitely that vacant jobs
have so it's just it's just a wrinkle to
keep in mind because this would seem to
be the year to at least considered if
you can find a coach
who maybe is thinking about leaving and
a team that maybe is thinking about
letting him go this could be the time to
do it yeah i i understand that i think
this could set up to be a very
interesting off-season because of like
you're saying some of the jobs that are
available and then also
i think you know just because you hit on
it the quarterback conversation i think
there's going to be a lot of good
quarterbacks available too via the draft
and free agency to where
you know you're gonna have some
interesting decisions made there by
teams that right now or like maybe in
limbo about their quarterback hey matt
stafford come here hey sam darnold
they're gonna draft trevor lawrence
we'll trade for you come here we think
you could be a starter matt ryan what's
gonna happen there with the falcons i
mean there's a there's a lot of guys and
names out there where you go where does
he end up next year how does that work
out um you know the coaching search is
always fascinating but i think it could
be a lot of moving chairs with
quarterbacks too
this offseason you know last offseason
was so upside down because of the
pandemic this offseason could be even
more fascinating tom brady hovered over
he sucked all the oxygen out of the room
frankly last offseason there's a lot of
wrinkles and a lot of different ways
that things are going to go this year
it's going to be fun but we got a lot of
football to be played before we get
there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports